alors on a caché dans les filières
qu'est ce que tu veux la pochette de rim
[Musique]
téva grisons c'est dur saramon céleri et
wilson tu vas te régaler avec ce jeu oui
je me casse et ça continue très
longtemps ah c'est vrai qu'ils font les
amours je suis pas sérieusement si si
bas les mecs
mariella 2 non non non mais leïla réveil
cinéma il aurait aimé seller de
l'ancêtre oui on a gardé aussi bon bah
tu tu feras tu étais réclamations
également l'instant vanille en fin
d'émission vous saurez qui est le ou la
38e tard baba on va voir partir tu va la
prendre la gold abx a aussi décoché bon
série chaque jeudi je prouve que vous
êtes animateur le plus élégant des
paysans français avec un style
vestimentaire en faux lagarfeld
balenciaga et kiabi et surtout un
langage entre celui de stéphane bern et
booba vous en foutez ce que je dis c'est
par avons cherché et vous détailler sur
vos chroniqueurs qui commence à parler
comme vous même une personne inattendue
alors pour la phrase la plus élégante de
la semaine les nommés sont j'adore
jean michel maire qui a du mal à vous et
comment il a occupé sa nuit oui la
journée très tard au japon ce matin
projet fait quoi j'ai beau ce nom mais
elle avait traité non c'est du ggd à son
mignon se mange arrive pas qu'est ce que
vous êtes
je vous fais un cube géraldine maillet
qui au bout de quatre ans commencent à
s'adapter à tpm paix et vous allez voir
qu'elle même est très choquée moi c'est
très dur parce que changer une couche on
va au bout d'un moment aussi fait avec
les siens avec ses gosses mais quand
c'est pas le sien la merde des autres
c'est compliqué
et cyril hanouna qui reste le meilleur
pour faire la promotion de l'émission
qui commence juste à prêter pmp kanté
pmp se terminera il ya top chef qui va
démarrer chez nous ce sera entre lui
assurant qu est chaud de tension
course-poursuite milliardaire sauce
tomate et rudi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que moi je regarde scène comme ça
moi je regarde je regarde des trous du
neuf cent mille alors à votre avis qui
va vous choisissez la caisse cheryl est
parce que l étonnante moi c'est pas
étonnant c'est une surprise d'abrutis
éternellement
nous entendons souvent parler de cette
façon donc c'est moi sur bien sûr bien
entendu une analyse complète de stéphane
bern stéphane burban c'est l'émission on
rigole le plus après bien sûr
téléshopping chaque soir c'est
l'overdose the dark à tous les
chroniqueurs balance des vannes qui
pétille comme des bulles de champagne
alors pour la meilleure vannes les
nommer à son
le restaurateur acquis cyril hanouna
veut faire une blague et finalement
c'est l'arroseur arrosé
ils veulent devenir ce soir le mange
ibiza d'accord je consulte cyril honda
qui rebondit sur la vie de qualité de
bélie à propos de l' envie d'adopter
sion de célyne durand 51 ans sans enfant
il va alors j'espère qu'elle va
l'adopter il aura peut-être quinze ans
[Applaudissements]
docteur j'ai mes points de retraite ses
jolies jambes et jean michel maire pour
une vanne qui mêle beaux esprits et
poésie
apparemment ils ont décidé de mettre une
plaque honorifique c'est en disant que
kim kardashian et les ailes de poulet 7
g/t au chai de la gare de lyon
[Rires]
hélas aujourd'hui bravo bravo alors si
vous avez plusieurs spécialités être à
l'antenne 18 heures par jour le ping
pong mais aussi les lapsus
ah oui oui en ce moment je passe vous
avez vous l'habitude c'est beaucoup vous
l'absolu c'est l'abbé lapsus et c'est
aujourd'hui que vous n'arrêtez pas de
lapsus et on va bien vous allez voir
vous avez fait notamment une qui est
extraordinaire à lapsus magnifique alors
pour le meilleur lapsus de cyril hanouna
les nommés sont
cyril hanouna qui sans le vouloir nous
balance un scoop sur gilles verdez
derrière les apparences un tout petit
peu moins glamour et sexy quand même oui
mais toi et ton mec ça doit toit de
tomates à l'offre mais c'est vrai dingue
lapsus cyril hanouna qui n'arrive pas à
cacher qu'à 20h30 ils crèvent la dalle
florent pagny était le président de
cette 35e cérémonie des victoires de la
cuisine et de la cuisine claire et cyril
hanouna pour le lapsus le plus
révélateur de l'histoire de la
télévision française
en tout cas je lui dis 6 et 8 veut que
je reste
voilà et que si le grand patron du
groupe canal vox jaurès bien entendu je
resterai puisque il est hors de question
que je leur fasse un coup dans le dos et
eux nous ont donné notre chaîne
notre science sur ses 8 ans
alors il est vrai dire il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont réagi hier sur ce j'ai dit
des césar je voulais je vous dit et les
patrons encore ce matin je les ai eus au
téléphone
gérald brice viret francs capitaux
vincent pu comme ça ils m'ont tous dit
franchement c'est ça qu'on aime la
liberté de ton et si on ne critique pas
nous mêmes aux critiques qui ont peut
pas critiquer les autres soient là et
donc voilà je pourrais encore les
remercier parce que c'est très rare
d'avoir une telle liberté sur une chaîne
hbo la gratuité ça fait les titres
aujourd'hui bien sûr vous voyez c'est
énorme et ça les a fait marie que ça ait
fait les titres voilà comme d'habitude
alors bientôt en scène de quelques
minutes le retard baba le 31e on verra
mais juste avant une petite sélection
des meilleures blagues de la grosse
rigolade la semaine à faire comme
d'habitude grosse rigolade qui va
revenir bientôt selon clément guérin à
vous je faisais la blague la plus drôle
parmi ces trois nommés vous êtes prêts
j'aurais très prochainement ouais un
très gros scoop à vous donner sur la
grosse rigolade a vraiment ça va changer
beaucoup de choses c'est vrai je me
direz vous et je vous dirai bientôt pas
tout de suite voilà dans mais je vous
dirai ce qui va se passer avec la grosse
rigolade d'accord ben écoute en
attendant l'e3 les trois blagues on
avait plaisir à viande hachée
[Musique]
philippe leleu moucheurs
c'est dans une banque au guichet il dit
moi la [ __ ] je dois voir le taulier
de ta merde là la femme effet pardon
monsieur j ecoute moi connaissent déjà
tu me regardes pas quand tu me parles
elite appelle le connard qui fait une
boucle à fait monsieur vous êtes
complètement fou d'y faire là bien ta
gueule apple le taulier ça la femme en
panique qui appelle le monsieur le
directeur venez vite ya un vrai problème
il ya un espèce de fouilles fait
monsieur il c'est toi le connard qui
tient à tony shepard on y lit ouais
c'est bien toi y lire oui je suis le
directeur de cette banque monsieur dit
oui et l'hygiène gagne au loto et j'ai
150 millions à mettre ici a dit d'accord
et c'est cette [ __ ] qui vous emmerde
liane foly une longue elle va au cinéma
vos choix d'armes je voudrais un ticket
psy look elle devenue donna ticket elle
saura elle revient mais juste mais
trente secondes après bonjour madame je
voudrais atik et s'il vous plaît la dame
lui donne un ticket j'ai peut-être un
copain qui arrivait derrière un truc
voilà revient 2 3 4 secondes plus tard
je voudrais un ticket s'il vous plaît à
2 cm excusez moi mais je vous en ai déjà
vendu 2 ha oui mais à chaque fois que je
rentre dans la salle ya un mec qui me
les déchets
et mohamed benyamna plus connu sous le
nom de bouder c'est un bug comme ça à
aux jeux je suis à côté d'un dac kaka
euros il sera à côté d'un cac cadavre nu
mais vous êtes tous du chu russe
assassin tiré samedi
mais non mais non non la rue saint csf
le figra lamari raccroche famille dit
après rappel de bec à l'eau c'est rocco
j'appris du kkk quelqu'un qu'animé vous
êtes tous quel rush et rue saint saint
saint saint 10 rue saint denis nord oui
c'est certain
maria jose or après le bey qui rappelle
à l'eau dd oui je suis à côté d'un
quinqua cas grec était plein coeur du
velvet qu'elle rudisha russe à sa jolie
russe ami eddie lui ai dit me promenais
pas dupes ils tort ni deux le temps de
déplacer le calme
[Rires]
beaucoup d'air et effet l'activité aux
magnifiques l'impoli on peut pas
dépareillé franchement les trois je les
remercie parce qu'ils ont fait cette
émission un grand succès qui peu louche
liane foly me ferez boudé avec tous ceux
qui sont venus et ont vraiment ils sont
venus très très souvent et je les
remercie chaleureusement parce que ils
ont fait de cette émission l'énorme
succès qu'on connaît merci à vous tous
merci mon chéri on a le tabac musique de
suspense ou de suite on va aller musique
de suspense qui sera le 31e tarn à bas
qui est le plus tacler cette semaine ses
collègues series s'il est battu ce soir
comme teddy riner la semaine dernière à
ce que ce serait un gros choc pour nous
ben je vous dire ce sera un choc mais ce
serait aussi un soulagement
c'est vrai que j'ai énormément de
pression tout l'estimerait toutes les
semaines c'est dur eh bien je tremble à
l'idée de vous annoncer que ce soir le
31e tabac
on voulait voir c'est pas ça de ma mère
ça de ma mère franchement c'est très
nouveau le voir pourquoi je le mérite
je pense que je méritais de cases
dédiées à isabelle c'est un grand cru
oui un très grand club isabelle et enfin
vous allez voir c'est pas mal
[Musique]
tiens clément garé mon chéri capable de
trois couples c'est jeanne et même 5 si
vous voulez où l'attend ordonné trois
c'est-à-dire déjà on s'en fout
effectivement qu'elle est un enfant car
c'est d'un collier antipuces pas droit
c'est une tension était vive hier contre
dans la misère
mais oui mais oui de misère entièrement
qu'est ce que vous pensez du
flexitarisme par exemple comment est ce
que je suis
sélection de voitures
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cela
[Musique]
j'aime bien les destins incroyables
berry et d'un destin c'est un concours
de beauté c'est pas une marianne dit on
s'en fou qu'elle est décent mais je
trouve qu'elle a un an vous et quelle
est elle les manistes ce voyage on a
accouché et on va vous n'êtes pas que je
sois là ben hameda c'est un peu juste
s'il vous fait la dalle en milieu bouge
encore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]